I think education must be the only
sector that hasn't already been
completely revolutionized by technology
you know I think about even how we do
our work within Teach for America or
teach for all now versus 10 years ago
and it's completely and totally
different just based on you know the
power of technology so there is no doubt
I mean we're not leveraging technology
in the way that we absolutely must if
we're going to ensure that kids truly
attain an excellent education given how
far we need to go in that pursuit from
where we are right now and I think
there's so much the technology can do
you know we should be thinking about how
to use the gaming technology that is so
addictive for kids to good end for
educational purposes you know we can
with with you know we should be able to
do so much to get our teachers and our
parents and our kids all clear on you
know where kids are relative to where
they're supposed to be based on rigorous
standards so that I mean the most
powerful way that motivate a kid is to
tell them here's where you are against
where you're supposed to be like they
become obsessed with getting where
they're supposed to be parents are dying
for that information teachers themselves
would benefit a lot from you know better
information on that score and if we
could get that information all in the
hands of all those folks at the same
time right there we would you know we
would improve a lot we should be
individualizing instruction like
utilizing that data to actually give
teachers the tools necessary to meet the
needs of a very diverse group of kids
which exists in every class so there's
just there's so much we need technology
to do at the same time you know I've
been somewhat disconcerted by some of
the discussion that goes on around
technology and education because it
almost you know and and this this seems
extreme but I've sat in rooms full of
folks who think that we could like give
kids tablets and that's it like they're
gonna teach themselves and I just think
in the end especially when you're
working with the most marginalized
kids the kids who are facing so many
extra challenges who don't have safety
nets they have the opposite of safety
nets around them you know I just think
it's gonna I don't think we're gonna be
able to replace just the the kind of
importance and power of personal
relationships you know whenever we've
seen the kids in the most kind of
disadvantaged context truly excel always
it's been in classrooms and in whole
schools where there is a clear vision of
where the kids have the potential to be
where there are people working
incredibly hard to convince the kids
that they can succeed if they work hard
enough and that it will make a
difference in their lives
you know there's so much that goes into
building a culture of achievement you
know and and there's a lot that that
goes on that could be you know better
done with technology as well you know
like if we if the teachers and the
principals in those schools how to
access to really great technology they
could no doubt speed up learning but I
just don't think we're gonna be able
what we need is all of that together you
know technology alone won't be the
panacea but if we can bring it to bear
within a context of all the foundations
that are important for quality education
it can be a huge accelerator